bonjour est elle un jour c'est patrick
patrick bruel
bon à lire tout alors écoute ici tu vas
fermer les yeux je veux rester les yeux
ouverts je suis un monsieur
il joue vrai j'ai un moment et je vois
je suis je me dis si on n'y ait plus
aucun si roland qui choqua droit donc
ils sont au piano au piano mais si tout
est ok nous tairons dit me verrais mal à
karin viard piano d'accord c'est
beaucoup mieux que ce soit lui au piano
c'est toi ou bien parce qu'ils aient
truc encore israël et anima kosovare
qu'elle soit sur la scène avec un micro
une fois que j'en vois un peu non bah là
quand j'ai cette fois mais si c'est pour
ces moments de bonheur de joie et de
fous rires
ça pue
[Musique]
ça fait dix ans
que vous êtes présents
dans votre votre dans votre canapé sans
jamais nous happer depuis le début
vous m'avez soutenu
personne ne pensait qu'on pourrait le
faire mais par contre dix on dénombre
désormais
[Musique]
on sait jamais lâché même les beautés
le plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il faut détacher le onze de ses jumelles
petites routes
voilà le vis du royaume notre deuil dans
le vrai pour une faute sur une hauteur
de niro fait jésus si c'est possible
c'est bien qu'ils aient une espèce de
petite phrase et rythmiques genre est
pour faire une chanson facile facile
d'abord des paroles qui va suivre un
poil aznavour toi d'abord des paroles
débit d huile une petite mélodie qu'il
ya des retards etc qui te prend la tête
et une chorégraphie pour bien faire à la
fête dans celle là on se rassemble à 5 à
6 août sachets tu le sens comment ça tu
veux le faire l'hyper parodique genre
lyrique sérieux au sérieux alors ça
alors là il faut que tu sois content
comme ça avec des grande consommation
comme l'argent comme ça pour faire une
chance soit tu veux faire votre avis
voilà la charte du monde doit viser le
gène du monde a confié un ami de porc
fraîche seule chanson
facile facile aux fondeurs des pays de
l'est mais j'y crois
la crète et chorégraphie pour bien faire
la fête danser dollar
en sera sans au passage à shanghai
[Musique]
la chance de sa vie de tous les
syndicats
qu'est ce c'est au fond de cette boîte
est touchant de la ville entre lui
l'état robert cette boîte tuerie mais je
les ai mis dans la boucle et n'arrivait
à patrick tu vois mais c'est quoi
j'aurais faire un produit avec moi je
lui réponds l'équipe chapelle restaurant
et je suis parti ben ouais ouais
et il ya tous plus bonjour est un bon
jour c'est patrick patrick bauwen
bonjour j'aimerais savoir s'il était
possible de réserver une table pour eux
ce soir peut-être c'est aurait sur le
match j'avais j'étais venu avec qui
adore michel exactement pensera que ce
serait pour ce soir pour une table ça
peut être aussi 5 6 ou peut-être sept ou
huit
je ne sais pas peut-être peut-être d'ici
on va serrer la vis je vais vous
confirmer dans dans une devient
maintenant peut-être raté leurs 15 ou 30
45 ou même deux heures
merci merci merci merci
[Musique]